salle de repos avec billards et
baby-foot cafétéria ambiance dinner un
esprit californien et pourtant nous
sommes à guyancourt où se situe la
société asmodée 150 personnes
travaillent ici on mise surtout sur
effectivement des espaces et des
conditions de travail idéales et on joue
effectivement sur wii le bien-être au
travail alors c'est un peu facile quand
on s'appelle asmodée et qu'on distribue
en fait on est dite ou distribuer des
jeux de société l'entreprise qui a
réalisé en 2010 7 450 millions d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires possède un
catalogue de plus de 2000 références
parmi les plus gros succès jungle speed
time's up ou encore les cartes pokémon
le siège s'est implanté puis récemment
étendu sur un terrain vendu par saint
quentin en yvelines
en tout douze mille mètres carrés c'est
la société j'ai fait qui a réalisé les
travaux à ce mode ayant voulu rester sur
le territoire pour asseoir son
développement nous avons adjoint une
deuxième tranche de locaux de 2000 m² de
bureaux et intégrée 90 parking en sous
sol
faisons en sorte qu'à ce modèle puisse
rester sur le territoire et dans son
bâtiment d'origine
le groupe continue
à se développer c'est un peu dans notre
adn je crois ce développement
je pense qu'effectivement le jeu encore
voilà de belles années devant nous
leader européen des jeux de société à ce
mode et se définit comme un groupe
français à dimension internationale
la société emploie d'ailleurs plus de
600 personnes à travers le monde